[Music]
thank you so I stopped online dating
I'm done now I just say it the
old-fashioned way I just walk outside
and hope
that's it that's how people used to date
10 or 15 years ago you would just put
makeup on and walk outside and be like
shut up
I hope it's today so I'm 6 feet tall and
I was 6 feet tall when I was 14 years
old and when you're that young and
that's all you look stupid you're like
hi I'm really tall I'm a freak who wants
to be my friend I have scoliosis kids
make fun of you so teachers are really
nice to you so they say nice things like
hi Carmen you should be a model because
you're so tall and when that's the only
reason people give you to be a model is
because you're tall one day you realize
it and you're like what about my face my
face wants to be a model too
and my face can hear you I don't have
any kids there okay they're just too
honest you know like I was with my
friend's kid he's seven years old and he
came up to me the other day and he's
like do you want to play truth or dare
and I was like okay truth and he's like
do you like being alone and I was like
you're a dick
you totally get me too bad you're so
young
I'll wait 11 years for you since you
know me so well I'll probably still be
alone my friend just got dumped by this
guy like really hard so she wanted to
lose weight so she lost 40 pounds she
went she had acupuncture they stick
needles into your body and all the air
comes out
[Laughter]
and now she's thin and her ex-boyfriend
wants her back and she's like you can't
have this and I was like good for you
that must have felt really good after
some guy hurt you like I got jealous
like I want to do that I want to get
dumped and then I'm gonna lose 40 pounds
but I'm gonna scared the [ __ ] out of my
ex-boyfriend
[Applause]
you did this to me sometimes when I'm
sad I go online and I read quotes and
they make me feel better you know like
love like you've never been hurt or eat
like nobody's watching or dance like you
don't need the money
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my parents just celebrated their 40th
wedding anniversary
40 years I don't know how they do it
they make it look so hard my mom is
Spanish Spanish people are so dramatic
you can't ask them anything get a
straight answer everything gets to come
from this soap opera part of their brain
like when I was a kid I would ask my mom
all the time mommy who do you love more
me or my sister it's a very simple
question coming from a child but she
would always go well if I had a gun if I
had a gun and someone said to me you
need to shoot one of your kids I don't
know which one of you I would shoot
and it's the same thing as saying I love
you guys the saying there's no need to
bring a gun into this story sure how
scared I was of my mother growing up
always wondering if I was gonna upset
her always thinking about what if I make
her snap do you know how relieved I was
when she finally killed my sister
[Applause]
you